in 1942 the Beveridge report famously
warned against the five giant evils want
disease ignorance squalor and idleness
and eventually led to the founding of
the welfare state for decades preventing
the five evils was accepted as a must
for social cohesion so it was a great
shock when I recently read about them
wearing their ugly head again on a South
London housing complex segregation isn't
legal in the UK but developer henley
homes and management company warwick
estates have been accused of precisely
this by barring children living in
social housing flats from using a
playground preserved or reserved shall I
say for private tenants through this
practice alone they are inflicting at
least three of beverages evils want
ignorance and idleness on kids who
already have the odds stacked against
them it's beyond a disgrace the wall has
now been taken down but only after media
attention and the social housing
management company agreeing agreeing to
pay towards the cost of the shared space
the ramifications of these kinds of
defensive practices are dangerous for
society on so many levels and local
authorities need to heavily find or
revoke the licenses of developers who
are tearing communities apart for
monetary gain I think you're right June
I mean I live we're not asking you I
think that it's absolutely reprehensible
that councils are allowed to sell-off
open space playing fields for monetary
gain for developers yeah I live in a
London borough the raw bar at Kensington
and Chelsea which everyone says the
leafy royal borough in it's filled with
parks and communal gardens but the parks
are open access but the communal Gardens
are locked and only those who own
property around the communal garden have
access to them and I live on one of
those myself and this topic has made me
really think about that because you have
a key I don't need a key because the
garden is literally at my backdoor and
that's how it works so you have a Square
Garden Square
it's called Hyde Park I have I
recognized everyday how lucky I am to
live on that garden there is also some
social housing on my garden and June I
regret to tell you that the social
housing has got a wall and the people
who live on the communal garden do not
have access to their own communal garden
fire because there it's exactly the same
thing I think they may they may be able
to apply to a key to go through one of
the two gates on either side yeah but
that's a price I think they do but you
know if they lose their key they can't
get it why do you disagree this features
almost as many characters as the
conservative leadership race so let's
just talk you through the runners and
riders or the players involved Lambeth
Council have strongly criticized the
segregation measures June Henley Holmes
they built the flats accused of blocking
off the playground after planning was
approved the guiness partnership the
management company for the social
housing tenant said it only controls the
social housing block and can't change
access to private areas of the
development Waurika states the
management company for the private
tenants defended its decision to keep
social housing residents out of shared
spaces as they don't contribute towards
the service charges and following a
meeting between the companies it was
agreed all residents will use the play
areas the guiness partnership will pay a
contribution towards the service charges
just get it all there the reason Greg is
simply this and I get all the injustice
but if you have one group of tenants
here who are paying towards the service
and upkeep of the facilities and they
are paying and you have another group of
residents living here who are not surely
those who are paying and contributing to
keeping that going have the entitlement
to it now we're not with you
is it a little Johnny here wants to
invite Sarah from there to go of course
they complete it no no that's wrong
that's wrong but as rook as regards can
Sarah just come over without anybody and
no because they're not paying towards it
I can't go and play God I can't pick
terrible governor I can't go and go and
play pro golf on a private locals unless
I contribute towards it I can go to a
public golf course it's the same can I
just come back and then I'll bring you
in
Club this isn't it's a posh private gym
for the adults this is a playground and
the terrible thing about this situation
is the children could see and actually
we have a quote here from one of the
residents and it's just heartbreaking
this is Esther Al and she said this is a
community and we have to be there for
each other
my kids are looking out the window at
the kids playing in the summer and they
feel nearly finished and they feel bad
they ask me mummy why am I not allowed
there and I can't explain I can't say
it's because they're rich and we're poor
so I just say we're not allowed they are
paying for that facility and this group
is not kids kids at eighteen three are
being told at that age they're not good
enough
you've got nice bit of grass then that
swing is not is nice in a few years
we've laughed at Prince Charles and his
life was a crazy ideas thirty years ago
he came up with the idea for a
development in a place called Poundbury
in Dorset where he wanted he wanted
people privately owned people to live
alongside people in social housing and
and you ought to see that development
now because this is what it does to the
mindset of people whereas this damages
it what Charles has done which is
astonishing so you have a beautiful
private house with a million quid and
obviously do you have a row of social
houses but they're all built by the same
architect and they're all stunning and
because the poor people want to live in
this environment and so they take care
of it and it's incredible and I'm base
rails the aspiration comes into the
whole of housing policy I mean for years
we built large council estates there
were only four council tenants for years
and then I think we understood that
actually mixed housing would be far
better and actually actually people
could should live alongside some people
who can't afford to buy a house to live
in the council house but but they will
live together and the funny thing about
this too is it reminds you of those
terrible pictures from Northern Ireland
you know where you saw the wall but
and you just local started planning
authorities are still doing this because
what they're saying it to a lot of
people who are there is a requirement to
build some social housing but they don't
have to build it there they can build it
somewhere else that's happening quite a
lot yeah
can we hear from somebody who's actually
worked on this Lord O'Neill Jim O'Neill
who's on the Commission for social
housing what the commissioners
recommended them throughout to beyond
the commissioners of is a extremely
ambitious number of so-called social
houses I'd like to call them social
homes when I was a kid that be called
council houses in order to give people
that don't have a lot of income
somewhere secure and safe and nice to
live so that was chairman of Chatham
House that this has only been resolved
of course because the tenants management
organization has agreed to pay towards
it's been resolved it's because of the
public in one playground I told you that
it happens on my garden this happens
across the country with something that
he's not right to think of an open space
and open access playground which should
really farm for people exactly you you
want some children to be more
antagonizing us just for the sake of it
I don't believe it works you're one of
those private developments you would be
happy with the poorer children not being
allowed to know I'm happy that this
Management Association is now paying
towards the funding of the swings and
the rides and whatever else it breeds
the kind of bitterness and anger then in
later life explodes to this war between
the classes and that's how it happens
obviously I don't want to bring this
back to the B word but it's that no it's
just these sorts of divisions that leads
to where we are now division this is
your social segregated
it's like we had social segregation so
council housing for years years we built
enormous estate sometimes outside
outside of cities that for poor tenants
was completely different this is
something but and it's clear that there
is one part of the development that is
available to people with money and
there's another part for those who don't
you and that's even one look at some of
the what is now being built where you
people have got one side so they've got
to do 20% social housing or something
and you look at the social housing
compared to the rest yeah thank you no
you're not the bigger problem is the
fact that we're leaving social housing
to be built by the private sector that
is that in itself is insane at the
moment only 2% only 2% of properties
being built in the country are being
built by the state that's the product
then we go then we go back to the
Thatcher government and the selling
council houses and all of that towed and
they're actually Conservative Party at
that time didn't want social housing but
that idea was brilliant what went wrong
was it we've got to put this house in
order and move you're watching the
pledge on Sky News up next
[Music]